it's time for roses and Rose a I'm
wearing yesterday's makeup still you
guys I will always be real with you
and the reality is oh gosh look at me
I'm still wearing my makeup from the
Golden Globes this has been on my face
for more than 24 hours I have slept very
little and I am so excited to be here
with you talking about season long
21 22 season 22 of The Bachelor
episode 2 with re lion Dyke junior guys
I have a full bottle of wine tonight
because a someone gave this to me for my
birthday and I still haven't drank it
this is HB d
Lauren it's so nice and B because I am
stressed out by this season episode 2
stressing me out
[Music]
I'm worried let me tell you why because
I don't think we are seeing the
characters we need to see we don't have
say a Corinne we don't have say a chat
right out of the gate and the gates open
and we went through it and we're in you
know episode 2 of it so we kind of got a
little bit of villany character
something tonight but I feel like what
we're having a hard time balancing is
but this season seemingly and bringing
back re that's more old-school character
from the franchise the producers I would
guess wanted a more legitimate love
story that wasn't so like I'm here for
an Instagram fam kind of a story but we
don't want to lose the reality TV
characters to give the show character
you know I'm saying so let's get
so in the first few minutes it's like oh
my god we love re re eyes Ari's face
Ari's gentleman Lina's Ari's everything
and then we're diving into a one-on-one
and but shameless book this is the
one-on-one that I was on and let me tell
you it was a long day of shooting it was
in Malibu it was a gorgeous date and
Becca seemed really into Ari I think the
Beca with a see Becca with the C and Ari
have a real connection they did from
night one and I interviewed Rachel's oh
and she said those dresses that Becca
got to keep of hers Ari paid for those
himself okay mm-hmm I mean if I said
drink every time Ari is a gentleman I'd
be on the floor mmm lovely and you know
of course as we've heard about 67 times
now that Ari has a career in real estate
it's allowed me to slow down work and
yet we're going to keep playing up the
fact that he's a racecar driver
okay so Oh weird Becca gives the first
one-on-one and they all like come out to
see them off this is so strange I think
what the more two-cycle I just seen a
lot of people who were killed or injured
or lost body parts why why drink every
time we even give some shoes out of a
like treasure chest box for no real
reason he's on one knee again quite a
lot of getting down on one knee with
Becca
mm-hmm-hmm you were gonna buy this how
much would it cost in two words I mean
this was the pretty woman date and I
don't have a problem with that because
that is my favorite movie and I don't
care what anyone says I understand that
it's the story of a prostitute who was a
much younger than the man she ended up
with I get that it is not the best
message for women okay but I can love
that movie and they wouldn't let her
shop and Becca got to shop with Ari and
she came home with all these bags it
feels like a bridal shower
I know who said that Oh feel so down on
yourself II don't know he's gonna marry
Becca or maybe they did I don't know a
lot of the times after these shows are
over the people are like we could sense
their connection all along I don't know
what do you guys think I think that is
the one let me know so tell me your dad
passed away yeah Becca and Ari also had
like some good one-on-one conversation
Becca really opened up about losing her
dad and I'm gonna be really guys I lost
my dad as well and I really identified
with her conversation and I thought it
was really real and I think Ari is a
really good listener I have to give Ari
that he is a complete gentleman and a
really good listener
and I think on these one-on-ones you
know sometimes it's weird when people
open up too much on group dates but on
the one-on-ones you gotta open up
otherwise why be there so then we get oh
and she got to keep those earrings I got
cleaned up on this date you guys crystal
okay so then we get another one-on-one
date pretty quickly with crystal I liked
crystal in the first episode though I
did say I don't know how genuine she is
because she keeps talking about how
genuine she is and that's usually a red
flag a rose red flag everybody so oh my
god crystal is gonna meet Ari's parents
already oh my god I actually did not see
that coming and Ari's reasoning was
kinda cute he said that he wanted his
parents to know he's okay doing this
bachelor thing again probably because
Sean Lowe told me that Ari was almost
The Bachelor a couple years ago but they
picked Chris soules instead of him and
so I was probably pretty painful for Ari
and his family and so he wanted them to
know him okay so you brought Chris oh
look at this cute fun girl she's like
Barbie I'm fine I'm fine I'm good I'm
good I'm good crystal is like Barbie
isn't she do you guys like crystal let
me know the last time it was with Emily
this is huge so weird to anyone else
like I don't mean weird I just mean it's
he really really loved Emily yanks then
their conversation gets real crystal
talks about her really difficult
upbringing how her dad wasn't around how
her mom wasn't emotionally available
that was real and I liked it but then
crystal comes back and the crystal
versus Bibby
rivalry starts very subtly because
crystal says she doesn't really want to
tell the other girls about her an army
stay she wants to keep it private and be
honest like if you don't want to open up
that spine but it does seem shady well
they'd be out of them it's not really
fine with you is it it's not really fine
on your truth so then they go on a group
date the demolition derby and they're
like spray-painting the cars and was
anyone else really freaked out by this I
thought this seems so unsafe
they're gonna go on a demolition derby
they're literally putting all these
women in behind the wheels of vehicles
and having them run into objects and
each other
analyse analyse you guys this was when
finally this episode started to get fun
and by fun I mean bumper car trauma what
so Annalise is 32 and she's crying and
they're like Annalise what's wrong and
she says that you know I thought she was
gonna say that maybe she was in a really
bad car accident when she was younger
no she had a bad experience with some
bumper cars and here's where I have to
give the bachelor producers credit
because the editing was masterful they
did some kind of bumper car reenactment
or at least licensed footage from a
carnival and included the music and yeah
re comforts Ernie's like hey if you
don't want to do this you don't have to
PSA for everyone we are all adults if
you don't want to do something you don't
have to do it okay okay I think my
patience has been trialed a lot so
Bibiana is losing it frankly she's like
it's one thing after another here yeah
girl you signed up to be on a reality
show now we're getting into Beca with a
K and you guys I have something really
special to do right now because back o
with a C long hair brunette Becca and
Becca with a K short hair brunette Becca
are very quickly becoming frontrunners
so much so that our crew is divided on
their love for the Becca's let's bring
in point counterpoint with the roses and
Rose a crew here we go we're flying them
in
everybody meet Josue everybody meet JC
all right look at these lovely handsome
faces bachelors in their own right JC
loves Becca with a k and Josue loves
Becca with a C and now we will dissect
so Josue loves Becca with a C because he
says she's humble the girl next door
all-american and JC loves Becca with a K
because she's vivacious energetic and
surprising ah I agree there's so much to
love about both of them and Josue thinks
that Ari likes Becca with a C because he
bought her all those dresses and in the
words of this very intelligent man was
way why would you buy all those dresses
for a woman unless you want to see her
wear all of them
the simplicity of that statement blew my
mind
it's brilliant yes he bought her all the
dresses because he intends on seeing her
wear all the dresses he wouldn't waste
his money he's just now making his money
in real estate he can't waste it
this was brilliant to me men are
sometimes idiots no offense but
sometimes so brilliant in their
simplicity I should start watching this
show with guys all the time it's time
for roses and Rosie
[Music]
Ahri's meeting up with Becca and Becca
says some weird crap like I always have
a fur on me and something like we should
week - we got here is we got front where
should we don't like some and if they
really like each other they had their
first kiss on this episode I think it
was good but you know Becca I think
shows her age her young age because she
says I'm so for no drama movies it
please
Becca with the K have some standards
girl you don't have to be simple you can
cause drama and you don't have to be
easy to please you deserve the world and
all the furs that are in it so just
remember that okay I think that she's
trying to seem likable but like you can
be problematic the whole point of
finding someone who's right for you is
that they love you with all your flaws
right and that why we're here because
Julia Roberts loved Richard Gere with
all his flaws I mean you loved her with
all hers which I'm not sure what they
were but they certainly included that
she was a prostitute
okay I'm not worried because some girls
aren't a little weird
so I collect taxidermy crystal did steal
time twice when she already had a rose
okay if she done it the first time I
wouldn't have said anything but she did
it a second time and here's where the
tide turns on our beautiful surfer girl
crystal crystal first of all she goes
and grabs Ari and says hey baby
which leaves me uncomfortable already
it's like I get that you don't want
anyone but he's not your boyfriend you
know
and then Bibiana says if she doesn't get
her time it'll be a show please that
finally we're showing some character we
need some character we need some
character because it's a television show
meeting characters you know and Bibiana
did something so amazing she said that
you just dug a big-ass hole for yourself
which is the best example I've ever seen
of someone being able to say network
television
then the rose ceremony of course crystal
maybe on a bow they're sticking around
cien got a little more time tonight
which was good she won the demolition
derby I liked her from the first episode
with that whole elephant cuff link don't
forget anything and we had a fun moment
at the end here with Jenny who is Jenny
I don't know but she left like this
Jenny told re she wasn't sad about
leaving him she was sad about leaving
her new friends and then re like a dad
said I know I know it's hard you know
and I almost want him to be like I need
text meaning at home okay and let me
know you're there like that's how it
sounds I got broken up with for the
first time and then she said she thought
she'd end up with Ari
I'm confused Jenny I'm confused
this episode was a little weird but
showed some promise at the end and I'm
feeling hopeful and I'm feeling open and
I'm feeling ready to go on the journey
if the journey takes me where I want to
go which is into some more drama for my
mama and Ari's mama who made an early
appearance on this episode please tell
me what you guys thought of course make
sure to LIKE ET on Facebook and
subscribe to us on YouTube and you can
let me know over on social media what
you're thinking of this season
are you loving Ari are you lamenting
loss of Peter still by the way the cast
of Bachelor Winter Games has been
announced and we have everything you
need to know about Winter Games over to
ETA on comm shameless
[Music]
and I want to thank it was we and JC for
their surprise appearances in this video
on the Becca
vs. Becca debates would love to know
your thoughts on that as well which
Becca are you rooting for only time will
tell I love you guys so much
and I just really want to say a sincere
thank you from the bottom of my heart
I'm so overtired
and I'm so wearing black to support
women and me too and this was such a
great Golden Globes year I'm derailing
my bottom line I really love you guys
and even if this was an office ode I
love talking to you guys about and you
make my life worthwhile I was basing my
but I meant it by
[Music]